When you think of Disney movies, you immediately
associate them with a predominantly young
audience.
Of course, anyone can enjoy Disney offerings,
but it's only natural to assume that the people
behind them gear the content of Disney stories
solely towards children.
With that in mind, you don't tend to typically
associate Disney movies with adult jokes - but
they're actually teaming with them!
Writers know that, in order for young kids
to visit the theatre, they have to be accompanied
by their parents, so they love to slip a little
something in to keep mom and dad entertained
as well.
In this video, we'll run you through just
a few examples of that.
These are ten disturbing Disney jokes that
are hard for kids to understand.
By the way, don't forget to like, comment,
subscribe, and join the notification squad,
to make sure that you're always up to date
with our great new videos.
And before we start can you guess the movie
from these emojis?
stay tuned for the answer at the end of our
video and be sure to keep watching for fun
trivia questions and fun facts along the way.
1.
Wreck-It Ralph
In 2012's Wreck-It Ralph, the characters from
the video game in which Ralph is the villain
- Fix-It Felix, Jr. - have a party to celebrate
the game's 30th anniversary, but Ralph isn't
invited.
When he learns of the snub, he reacts angrily
and, upon seeing that Pac-Man was invited,
he calls him a "cherry-chasing dot-muncher."
Kids will have assumed "cherry-chasing" was
exactly what it sounded like, but adults knew
it was a reference to men who seek to take
away a girl's innocence!
2.
Bambi
Bambi is arguably the most quintessentially-Disney
movie ever made, so surely the 1942 classic
couldn't have any dirty jokes in it?
Right?
RIGHT?!
Well we're afraid you're about to have your
childhood ruined, because it absolutely does!
Bambi's skunk friend Flower finds himself
a girlfriend in the woods and, when the pair
accidentally kiss, Flower turns bright red
before his entire body becomes... well...
hard.
This was clearly a metaphor for male arousal,
but young kids would never understand that.
Trivia time: Bambi and Thumper have which
of the following named after them?
a) Two asteroids.
b) Two species of deer and rabbit.
c) Two taekwondo moves.
Find out the answer at the end of the video.
3.
Toy Story 2
The erection jokes just keep on coming!
(That wasn't meant to be one of them, by the
way) And this time it's in 1999's classic
Pixar sequel Toy Story 2.
When Buzz Lightyear first meets the cowgirl
Jessie, he is clearly attracted to her and
struggles to speak coherently as a result.
The attraction becomes even more obvious when
she spectacularly uses a toy car like a skateboard,
which makes his wings stand upright - yet
another clear metaphor for male arousal.
4.
Cars
Lightning McQueen - brilliantly voiced by
Owen Wilson - is the main character in the
Cars franchise.
He's an anthropomorphic stock car whose popularity
soars to legendary status as the movies progress.
In the first movie from 2006, he's the hot
new rookie, having his first experiences of
stardom - an example of which comes in the
form of having fans.
One such example sees two twins - Mia and
Tia - flashing their headlights at him, before
being led away by security.
When you think about what "flashing" means
in human terms, you get what was actually
going on there!
5.
Beauty and the Beast
In spite of the fact that he's undoubtedly
an enormous douchebag, it's impossible to
deny that Gaston from 1991's Beauty and the
Beast is the epitome of manliness.
He's muscular, he can fight and hunt, he drinks
a lot of beer and, in his own words, "every
last inch" of him is covered in hair.
The fact that he winks at the very same moment
that he uses the word "inch" would suggest
that he's describing himself in some extremely
intimate detail with those words - detail
that's only meant to be noticed by adults,
as a matter of fact.
6.
Aladdin and the King of Thieves
Aladdin and the King of Thieves was the second
direct-to-video sequel to the Disney classic
Aladdin.
The 1996 offering was nowhere near as good
as the original, but it still had the Genie,
and it still had his trademark humour and
wit as a result.
One such example came in the form of an adult
joke in the middle of Aladdin and Jasmine's
wedding.
A stampeding elephant causes a small tremor,
which results in Genie saying "I thought the
earth wasn't supposed to move until the honeymoon",
referencing the fact that a man and his wife
shouldn't...
cavort... until after they were officially
wed.
Trivia time: True or False - Pierce Brosnan
was originally cast in the role of Cassim
in this movie?
All will be revealed at the end of this video.
7.
Hocus Pocus
1993's Disney Halloween fantasy-comedy horror
- that's a mouthful - Hocus Pocus followed
three witches who sought to regain their youth
by sucking the souls out of the children of
Salem.
Upon their resurrection in modern times, therefore,
they told a bus driver that they "desired
children".
Mistakenly thinking they meant they wanted
him to father their children, the driver responded
by saying "it may take me a couple of tries,
but I don’t think there'll be a problem!"
8.
101 Dalmatians
Okay, we'll get right to it - the 1996 live
action adaptation of 101 Dalmatians had a
bestiality joke.
Glenn Close's Cruella de Vil delivered it
when Roger Dearly spoke about how he and his
wife were expecting a baby and their pet was
expecting some puppies.
De Vil responded by saying "you have been
a busy boy", suggesting that Roger was responsible
for the conception of both the baby and the
puppies.
Thank goodness that one went over the heads
of the movie's younger audiences members.
Yuck.
9.
The Avengers
The Avengers was the first movie in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe to be distributed by Disney,
so we can definitely include it on this list.
The 2012 offering saw the titular team coming
together to face Loki - and it's an interaction
between him and Tony Stark that we're referring
to here.
When Loki failed to mind-control Stark with
his scepter, thanks to Stark's arc reactor
blocking its effects, Loki said "this usually
works".
Stark then makes fun of Loki, citing "performance
issues", which definitely isn't meant for
kids' ears, as it jokingly refers to men having
problems performing in the bedroom.
Trivia time: Complete this quote from the
movie - "Doth mother know you weareth her
?what?"
We'll give you the answer at the end.
10.
Frozen
2013's Frozen - the highest-grossing animated
movie of all time - is something of a love
story, but it has no problem calling out silly
stereotypes in other classic tales of romance.
When Anna reveals that she planned to marry
Hans after only knowing him for one day, both
Elsa and Kristoff question her sanity.
Kristoff goes as far as suggesting that Anna
knows nothing about Hans and starts asking
questions about him - including his foot size.
Anna responds by saying "foot size doesn't
matter" which, to adult audiences, was obviously
a humorous play on the notion that the size
of a man's... package... doesn't matter either.
The answers to the trivia questions were:
There are two asteroids named after Bambi
and Thumper.
Pierce Brosnan wasn't in fact original cast
as Cassim, but another James Bond actor was
- none other than Sean Connery.
And the missing word was "drapes".
Thanks for watching our video about ten disturbing
Disney jokes that are hard for kids to understand.
Do you know of any other jokes in Disney movies
that were clearly aimed at adults?
And the answer to the movie emjoi is: [insert
answer here]
Did you get the right answer?
Let us know in the comments below.
And make sure you subscribe to our channel
and sign up for notifications so you never
miss an upload.
If you liked this video, check out our buddies
over at CBR.
Their videos cover the entire pop culture
spectrum and are every bit as aweseome as
the one you just watched.